-Our first guest tonight
is an Academy Award
winning actress whose new film
"She Came to Me"
is in theaters tomorrow,
October 6th.
Please welcome back to the show,
the very talented,
our dear friend
Anne Hathaway, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, Anne.
-Thank you so much.
-I'm so happy you're here,
and I want to congratulate you.
Our lives run in parallel
in many ways.
We just -- my wife
and I celebrated our 10th.
You guys just celebrated
your 11th anniversary.
-Happy anniversary.
-Congratulations.
-Congratulations to you, too.
-Thank you very much.
What did you guys do
for the big 11?
-Got rained out.
-You got rained out?
Was it this...?
-Yes, it was this past Friday?
-Oh, yeah.
That's a terrible day.
That's literally the skies
sending an omen, yeah.
-That you should just
let your ambition be dead.
-Yeah.
-And so we did, we did.
We just kind of like,
re-pajamaed
-Oh, that's nice.
-I think if you can
re-pajama with someone
that means that
you've chosen the right mate.
--You know, I had a moment
when I was curled up
on his chest,
and we were watching, like, hour
three of "Abbott Elementary,"
and I was like,
I'm so happy.
-There you go.
-This is the right guy for me.
And I did have that thought that
that I --
What did you guys do?
-We, it was September 1st
and we had --we had
a lovely dinner party
where we all -- it was
a five couples --
and we all went around
and talked about
how we met, the day we met.
And unfortunately,
the last person,
the last guy who told the story
made it -- was way more romantic
than the first
four guys had been,
in a way that we all were like,
"Could we go again?"
-Actually, I want
to change my answer.
-I would love to change it.
I didn't realize you were
allowed to talk like that.
-You and I met
just for the first time
just before he and I met
or got together.
-Really?
-Because, yeah,
in October 2008,
I hosted "Saturday Night Live"
for the first time.
-Yeah, I remember well.
-And then I went out to --
I remember it very well.
It was one of the most
exciting weeks of my life.
It still is.
And then -- and then I went out
to L.A. to work on a movie,
and that's when Adam
and I got closer.
And then it was
the North American premiere
of "Rachel Getting Married,"
the Jonathan Demme film.
-There you go, Jonathan Demme
is a great director.
-So that month in my life
was just crazy.
-That's so fantastic.
The other thing I remember,
The Killers were
the musical guests.
-Yes.
-And that was a --
that show also,
I should note,
was right after
the last writers strike.
That was, yeah.
-Oh, my gosh.
I forgot about that part.
Wow.
-And so it was we were
so happy to be back at "SNL"
and you were such
an exceptional host,
and so that was really special.
And it was just a -- it
was just a banger of a show,
I remember, start to finish.
But my parents were there
and The Killers
were the musical guests.
And my parents, I introduced
my parents to The Killers
who were really nice.
And as they walked away,
my mom said very loud
and they definitely heard,
"I don't know why
they call them The Killers.
They couldn't be nicer.
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "Well, did you think
they were murderers?"
-So my mom came to one
of my --
My little brother
did stand up for a while.
He's really funny,
and my mom and dad,
you know,
went to one of his shows.
And one of the comics
before him
explained Tinder
to the audience.
And then in the pause
that followed,
because most people
knew what Tinder was
but my mother didn't,
you just hear
my mom's voice ring out,
"Oh, that's awful!"
[ Laughter ]
-That's what you want to hear
on stage as a comic.
This -- So this film, this is
a beautiful independent film.
Obviously, there's
a SAG-AFTRA strike.
This is a film with a waiver
that is given
to some of the independent films
that are not made
under sort of the auspices
of the struck companies.
Is it nice to be able
to come up
and talk about sort of
one of these smaller films
that sometimes don't get
the same amount of attention?
-Yeah.
Yeah, it's amazing.
I mean, for a lot of reasons.
One, Rebecca Miller is
our writer and our director,
and I think she's been
working on this project
for close to a decade.
-That's amazing.
-It's amazing.
And she is the most brilliant,
talented person.
She's not just a director
and a writer,
but she's also an artist.
She's a painter,
and this is, the movie,
the screenplay is based
on a short story that she wrote
and then adapted herself
and then transformed.
It's all set
in the world of opera,
but it's also set
in the world of tugboats.
-That's --
-Which I know we've all
seen that movie a million times.
-It's such a bummer
because I have that idea
and I'm now like, huh.
-Did you?
I'm like, do it, do it before
someone beats you to it.
-It's that thing
where I love --
I love going to -- I love --
I love all kinds of movies.
You know, I'm not just like --
but what I think --
when I think that
we're at our best as an industry
and when I think
we're as our best,
like as an audience is
when we have different options.
And I'm just really proud to be,
I don't know,
part of an independent offering
that's totally original,
that's a little bit
like a French movie,
but without subtitles
and in English.
-That's very nice.
-[ Laughs ]
-Every time I watch
a French movie, I'm like,
"Couldn't you done it easy?
Couldn't you made it
easier for me?"
-For me, for me.
-Now I can't even look
at my phone during this movie.
-How rude.
-You --
and you auditioned
for Rebecca Miller years ago.
-I was a literal teenager.
-Wow.
And I auditioned for --
I auditioned
for her a week before I met you.
No, I auditioned --
-I remember you were
always like you
I'm so excited.
I just auditioned
for Rebecca Miller.
-I was 19 years old,
and she was making
an incredible movie
called "The Ballad
of Jack and Rose."
And I was going to Vassar
at the time,
and I was taking
a romantic poetry course.
And I remember going into
the audition,
and you know how it is.
You're like one fish
in a sea of an ocean
of actresses.
And I didn't know if I was
going to get the part,
but I just wanted to let
her know what the screenplay
had meant to me because
I really love her writing.
And I just handed her a poem
that reminded me
of the screenplay
that she'd written.
And so when I met her,
she was actually my last meeting
before the pandemic kicked in.
-Oh, wow.
-And I walked in and she goes,
"It's really nice to meet you."
And I said,
"Well, technically we've met."
And I remind her,
and she didn't remember me.
Hopefully my acting
has improved since then,
but -- but she did remember
the poem.
-Oh, and that's very sweet
to have a poem remembered.
She's like,
In all my years,
no one had
the nerve to hand me a poem.
-The nerve -- the nerve
or the nerd?
-It's a little, I think,
it's a combo of both
when you give someone a poem.
-A nervy nerd.
-[ Laughs ]
-That seems lovely.
-This is -- you're also a
producer on this film.
-I am.
-And I'm wondering, like,
how, you know,
because again,
you're this wonderful actor.
And then do you also
have to bring that in?
And this is what I also love.
This is such a great
New York cast.
Marisa Tomei and Peter Dinklage.
This is a real East Coast
posse right here.
And do you ever
as a producer go,
hey, maybe a little bit
more like this or do you...?
-What do you mean?
-Like, do you ever give
your other actors like,
hey, I just want to remind you
that I'm also, you know?
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah, good. Yeah.
-I have to.
-You got to, right?
You care about the product.
Your name's out there.
-I just don't know that
it's been a complete experience
since I've crushed the spirit
of the person that I'm with.
You know, that's just kind of --
What?
[ Laughter ]
I am kidding.
I promise.
-You should give
all your notes from here
on out via poem
and just be like,
I have something to say
about your acting,
but I would like you
to read a poem.
-Okay. So if I give --
I'm going to try this.
-Okay, good.
-Or I'm going to deny this.
-Oh!
-I don't know
if I can fly this,
but I'm going to try this.
-This is like a magic trick,
and I don't like it.
[ Laughter ]
I don't like how quickly
you're rhyming.
[ Laughs ]
-If you don't like it --
No, I'm just gonna stop.
-Okay, good.
I have more questions
to ask you, and we're going
to show a clip of the movie.
Right back with more
from Anne Hathaway.